in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen!
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 10th, on which we commemorate,
our venerable and God-bearing Father Ambrose of Optina.
Our Holy Father Ambrose, the most outstanding figure among the Staretsi,
elders of the monastery of Optina, was born in the year 1812.
He was a lively child of quick understanding, and his grandfather, a village priest,
took charge of his early education, bringing him up in the study of church books.
When he went to the seminary for his secondary education, as was then customary,
he did brilliantly as a student, but without the intention of becoming a priest or monk.
Towards the end of his studies, he fell seriously ill and made a vow to enter a monastery
if he recovered.
Once he was better, he put off fulfilling his promise, worked for a while as a tutor in a landed family,
and then spent some time teaching Greek at the junior seminary in Loupetsk.
His jovial, sociable nature was the cause of the fooling around,
as he called it later, that kept him in the world, but his conscience gave him no rest,
and he spent many hours in prayer and tears.
God called him and reminded him of his promise by all sorts of signs.
So, as he was leaning over the bank of a stream one day,
he heard a voice in the flowing water that murmured,
praise God, retain God.
After four years of indecision, he could bear it no longer,
and went to ask the advice of a holy hermit called Ilarion, who lived in the district.
The statets received him with a smile and said,
Go to Optina, you are needed there.
The young man was obedient to the will of God and went without delay to the hermitage of Optina
in the diocese of Caluga near the town of Kozelsk, a monastery that was on its way
to becoming the center of a widespread movement of spiritual renewal in Russia.
He was first put to serve statets Leonid,
who because of his old age entrusted him to the direction of statets Makarios,
who had taken over his spiritual responsibilities
and was working on an extensive addition of patristic texts.
The young monk received the tonture in the year 1842, with the name of Ambrose.
Three years later, he was ordained priest.
As he was proficient in the ancient languages, Ambrose became one of Makarios' closest fellow workers
in the preparations of his editions of the Holy Fathers,
especially of the Russian translation of the latter of St. John Klimakos.
His familiarity with patristic texts and their application to everyday life
through frequent discussions with his spiritual father,
with the best possible preparation for succeeding him as statets.
But here again, Providence stepped in and altered drastically the course of his life.
A serious illness brought him within an inch of death,
and for the remainder of his days he was more or less bedridden,
unable to serve the divine liturgy and relieved of all monastic obedience.
This was God's way of reigning in his genial temperament,
thus giving him the opportunity of greater self-knowledge
through retiring within himself and discovering within the depths of his heart,
the mysteries of human nature and the means of reconciling men with God.
Illness gave him experiential knowledge of the truth
that it is in our weakness that the power of God is revealed.
As he would later affirm, it is good for a monk to have passed through illness.
When he is sick, he ought not to strive to be cured completely,
but only by half.
Statets Makarios began sending brethren of the monastery to him for spiritual counsel,
and the bishop gave him the blessing to assist the statets,
in the task of confessing the ever-growing crowd of faithful from all walks of life,
who flocked to Optina in order to quench their thirst
at the pure springs of evangelic wisdom.
St. Ambrose welcomed all patiently, judged the faults of none,
and gave his advice simply as a disciple of the Holy Fathers,
without ever expressing a personal opinion.
The action of grace and unceasing inner prayer gave him an extraordinary insight
into the hidden depths of consciences,
so that a slight illusion or a few words was all he needed to show his visitors
the solution to their problems.
He never used this gift of insight to judge or blame,
but waited on care-worn souls with a sympathy and tenderness
that were truly maternal, so that they should understand that
the goodness of God leads us to repentance.
On the death of St. Ambrose in the year 1860,
Ambrose was called to exercise a ministry that soon extended to the whole of Russia.
Rich and poor, learned and unlettered, nobles and simple folk,
noted members of the intelligentsia,
they all made their way to this better-written man
as to a prophet newly risen among them, seeking a word of counsel
or of consolation in their distress,
a word of salvation that was to order their entire life,
a call to repentance, or a simple blessing.
Despite his physical weakness and his ailments,
Ambrose received them all cheerfully and would adapt his manner
and his words to each person,
so that after conversing with the statets of optina,
the life of many of his visitors changed completely.
People who spoke with him noticed how he could pass immediately
from the discussion of high theology to the solution of practical problems of everyday life.
Someone criticized him one day for wasting his time
advising a peasant woman how to feed her turkeys.
Don't you understand, he answered,
that her whole life is bound up with these turkeys
and that the peace of her soul is of no less account
than that of those who come to me with questions about sublime matters?
The writer Tolstoy visited the statets and was greatly edified.
I did no more than converse with him, he wrote,
and somehow my soul lost all heaviness.
When you talk with such a man,
you feel the nearness of God.
Another writer speaks of an unfathomable abyss of charity
within the saint whose love was extended to all.
The statets lived in the skit at a short distance from the monastery.
His day began about 4 a.m.
After reading Mattins with his cell servants,
he spent three hours in prayer.
Then from 9 a.m. he began to receive the visitors,
first the monks, and then the laypeople,
who were waiting in a long queue outside.
These meetings went on until 11 p.m.
with a short pause for a frugal meal.
During his few spare moments, he would deal with his vast correspondence,
dictating more than forty replies a day to letters
that he often had no need to open.
For about thirty years the blessed statets persevered in this ascetic labor
that was harder than many anaskecies performed in the peace of the desert.
A number of monks helped him in his task,
particularly his cell servant Joseph,
who succeeded him as statets of optina.
Rather than great ascetic efforts which can be infected with self-love
when they are not checked by an exact obedience,
the statets commended repentance to his visitors
and the humble contrition of heart that is acquired by turning one's life towards God
and by hating sin with all one's strength for the origin of all sin is pride.
Besides his ability in the cure of souls,
St. Ambrose organized associations of devout persons in many places
to undertake charitable work and to assist orphans and the poor.
Ever since the destructive reform of Catherine II,
it had been impossible for the daughters of poor families to lead the monastic life.
For each monastery had to demand a large dowry of every young woman who applied to enter.
During the last ten years of his life,
statets Ambrose sought to remedy this unjust state of affairs
by founding and organizing a convent for nuns at Shamordino about nine miles from optina.
Through his paternal care, this monastery was,
in a short time, inhabited by more than 1,000 nuns from every rank in society
who strove to live in perfect charity,
a life based on the traditions of the Holy Fathers around the person of statets Ambrose,
their spiritual father, and living image of Christ.
In addition to the conventional buildings, the statets built an asylum,
a school, a hospital, and a hospice for aged women,
so that the place became truly a city of Christian love
that attracted crowds of destitute, sick and unfortunate folk
for whom the monastery was a haven of hope and consolation.
The needs of the convent obliged the statets to be at Shamordino often,
and when they began building a stone church,
he found he would have to stay there to oversee the work of construction.
His absence led to rumors among the monks at optina
and disturbed the bishop of Caluga.
The saint spent the whole summer of 1891 at Shamordino,
attending to all the business matters that concerned the convent,
which the new abyss who lacked administrative ability could not deal with.
It appeared that Ambrose was in a hurry to finish his task
and was preparing for his departure hence.
At the beginning of autumn, overwhelmed with fatigue, he finally fell ill.
When he was told that the bishop had decided to come in person
to the convent to send him back to optina,
he received the bad news with complete composure.
And on the 10th of October, in the year 1891,
the day before the episcopal visit, he gave up his soul to God.
Until his last hour, he continued to receive the faithful
who crowded around his cell.
So it was that he fulfilled the prophetic words that he said again
and again to his disciples.
I have spent my whole life in the midst of the people,
and that is how I shall die.
All Russia wept with his passing.
He was laid to rest at optina,
beside Staretz Leonid and Staretz Macarius.
On his tombstone are carved the words,
to the weak I became weak,
that I might win the weak.
I have become all things to all men,
that I might by all means, save some.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.